Nobody believes I'm 37 anymore,
and I'm afraid to say it is from using salmon sperm.
That was my face just a month ago.
And this is all from using this one little Korean anti wrinkle stick
where a main ingredient is salmon DNA
aka PDRN, derived from salmon sperm.
Also got salmon collagen,
and those ingredients have been shown to deeply penetrate
skin molecules
to help stimulate collagen production on a cellular level.
Also got Juju oil to help lock in hydration.
And if you know anything about wrinkle prevention,
you want to deeply hydrate those fine lines
to help stop them from becoming wrinkles.
I've only been using this a month and normally my skin is such a deep,
dehydrated, dry mess this time of year.
We have a super dry fall and winter here in LA,
but I've been walking around with glassy,
glowy hydrated skin for the past few weeks now.
PDRN is insanely popular in Korea for this reason.
Celebrities are literally flying there
and paying up to $600 per injections into their face.
That's why this Kahi Multi Bounce Wrinkle Bomb
quickly became one of the fastest selling Korean beauty products
the year it came out in 2022.
It just came out in the States
and it's already selling crazy fast on TikTok Shop.
I had to wait a few weeks before they restocked,
but if you see an orange link on screen right here,
I would grab this very fast while it's still Available